so uh now that i'm in la and i'm on tv
i'm starting to feel all this pressure
to uh stay in shape get in get in shape
and even though it looks like i've been
making no effort whatsoever
i actually have been working out quite a
bit in my own way let's let's take a
look
so we're gonna start right here what's
your name jack jack hi jack and what's
your name hi i'm pete
should we talk about problem areas cause
mine's tummy and bum-bum
all right let's go on over to the red
circle so we can warm up our muscles and
isolate our problem areas
can you put your arms in front of you
like this arms in front of you all right
and ready
here we go i'm sweating already
that's not a joke
all right we're gonna do a dance parade
you guys should know when you get older
spinning is less fun
can you hit me like a baby
oh are you guys hey guys watch the horse
play hey hey
hey it's for horseplay pete you're in
the timeout we can't totally
wow
moms
got so much energy what do you feed
those guys
lunchables
right
you want to come over for dinner rebels
you like princesses i like
rapunzel
who's the princess and brave
lola what is it melody
murder that's a swear in spanish
apple juice good source of
60 juice
just wanted to let you know i'm going to
be on the bowel beam in a bit
it's what we call in the biz the bell
beam
i don't have time because i'm always on
the ballot beam
you ever rocked a bow beam
you want to see a grown man do it
anyone else tired of all this kid
willy-nilly stuff and want to see a man
own a balance beam
do you know how we turn on the jets
if we're gonna work out we're gonna need
something a little more fierce you know
what i mean get the blood going
you guys into this
you guys been to copenhagen
good idea got to cool down
i thought i'd get mocked last of the
kids jim
you